for me I like doing these interviews
because it gets me out of my own head
and and my own problems what is it about
doing documentary interviews that
interest you where do you see that
ending in IC the beauty and document um
what is I mean I said it's a it's a
obviously a kind of to see what its
likes me about doing documentaries is to
see different parts of life to different
people lies I can never live I'm in a
lot of ways it's kind of narrative films
that way too but to actually meet real
people per se you know I can meet
somebody who's 80 years old who who's a
sailor or something you know something
that I would never do none you know
would never have a chance to do in my
life kind of explore that and the seat
and a lot of ways it's kind of odd to
say this but to see how they're sort of
similar to me um and I hopefully that's
you know that's what it takes me about
watching documentaries to see it a
different life that I could never live
and how how did that person handle that
life so it's just like a more intense
version of watching a documentary in a
lot of ways of like oh I get to actually
meet that person and I can ask them what
questions I want to ask that person and
get you know and see their life
basically
you